in order to get engaged lead which is
people who show interest in the stuff
that you have to sell then it means you
have to show people who are not
interested and get them interested and
so the question is what is that bridge
that goes between not interested and
interested you give them value and you
give them value ideally around a problem
that you want to solve for them now how
you define the problem that you're going
to solve gets into the Nuance of how you
create a lead Magnet or offer but you
give yourself the opportunity to solve
their problem ideally for very low risk
which is either very cheap or nothing at
all and then by doing that you earn the
most valuable thing you can have in
business which is trust and then at that
point that's when the real conversation
begins and that's where monetization
starts